hi in this video I'll talk about antigen
presenting cells or a pcs first we'll
talk about the types of antigen
presenting cell then we will move on to
look at their development inside the
bone marrow and then finally we'll talk
about the functions of the antigen
presenting cells and their significance
in terms of the immune response now we
can consider the immune system our body
to be a defense system of our country
now if these two are similar then the
antigen presenting cells are very
similar to the patrolling police officer
why so we would know in a moment and we
would always compare our immune
situations with the defense crisis and
that would help us to understand these
concepts in a better way so let's
introduce our antigen presenting cells
they are dendritic cell macrophage
b-cells now all of these cells has
something common all of them display
antigens on class 2 MHC molecules now
let's talk about that development a
little bit so inside the bone marrow all
these a pcs are born and inside the bone
marrow there is lymphoid progenitor
cells from the lymphoid progenitor in
subsequent step the b-cells would be
produced
now b-cell when leaves the bone marrow
they're still immature but they
eventually leave in leave the bone
marrow and go to the bloodstream from
where they migrate to the peripheral
lymph node and there they become mature
and they start engulfing pathogen and
displaying their antigens on their MHC
molecules second we should talk about
tendrich cells dendritic cells can be
derived from the employed progenitor but
nowadays there is a debate that myeloid
progenitor can also give rise to tend
riddick cells the third type is
macrophage now macrophage is not
directly produced from the bone marrow
but myeloid progenitor give rise to
monocytes monocytes are secreted into
the bloodstream
now these monocytes when entered the
tissue space the different sheets into
the macrophages so now we understand how
macrophage dendritic cell and b-cell
develops from the bone marrow now let's
take a common example to understand the
function better let's say you are
jogging in the morning and suddenly
you're you've got your leg pricked in a
rusty nail and along with this rusty
nail a lot of pathogen entered your body
and these pathogens could be harmful for
your body right so first of all let's
see how our body reacts and how this APC
react
now our patrolling police officers which
are the macrophages which are always
patrolling near the physical barriers
they would understand that something is
wrong there is some pathogen and the way
they understand it is by the pathogen
recognition receptors or the toll-like
receptors etc dendritic cells have the
toll-like receptors as well they can
also detect the invasion of some foreign
substances now once they detect the
invasion of the foreign substances out
of many things one of the thing that
they would do is secrete cytokines and
these cytokines are alarming signals
which would bring more and more
macrophages and dendritic cells to the
site of the injury such that they can
combat the situation for block backup
you can imagine the situation that the
cops are calling for backup right so
this situation is very similar when a
terrorist invades a border now our
defense system or our armies are not
always deployed into the border right
but the patrolling police officers
always patrol the border and once
patrolling they would understand that
something has gone wrong they would find
some empty shells of bullet and some
magazines so they would first think okay
they might encounter a terrorist so they
would first try to encounter they would
call for backup
and they would always understand that
now the enemies could be very strong so
we should talk to our higher authority
dendritic cells do the same dendritic
cells have the pathogen recognition
receptor
by which it can understand what kind of
pathogen has entered our body then it
would try to engulf the pathogen by its
long dendrite like processes after it
engulf the pathogen it would degrade the
pathogen inside that and some part of
these pathogen or some part of these
pathogen would be displayed on to the
class 2 MHC molecules on the surface of
the dendritic cell and now once they
start displaying the pathogen derived
antigen on its surface it is the time
for the dendritic cell to report this
situation report report about this
hostile environment to the lymph node to
the T and B cells which are the reserve
army branch of the body so they would
then have their migrate towards the
lymph node now lymph node has specific
subdivisions subdivisions were t-cells
and b-cells recite you can imagine them
to be a army barak so inside an army
base there are separate army barracks
for separate army division officers
right so this is pretty similar the cop
which found that something has happened
wrong into the border he then and
they're moved to the army base and where
he informed about the hostile
environment to the higher army officials
our dendritic cells did the same thing
dendritic cell move inside the lymph
node they go to the para cortex were
t-cell recites they interact with the T
cell activate the T cell for the T cell
can activate the B cell now B cell once
get activated they quickly differentiate
into plasma cells which are antibody
secreting plasma cells some of these
plasma cells immediately leave the lymph
node and try to combat the situation
they are like the quick action force now
some of these B cells would also
proliferate and they would increase
their number so this can be thought
about the army which is a reserve brawn
branch of that eventually they can also
have the capability to
we differentiated into antibody
secreting plasma cells and these
antibody which these plasma cells are
secreting are against that pathogen
which can potentially neutralize the
pathogen so we learned that the T cell
with its T cell receptor interacts with
the MHC bound peptide and the signal
derived from the dendritic cell and the
cytokines derived from the dendritic
cell eventually activate the T cell once
the T cell is activated it also
activates a b-cell and B cell
differentiates into polar antibody
secreting plasma cells and since these
antibodies are against the pathogen
derived antigen so these antibodies
could neutralize the response in the
periphery in short these antigen
presenting cells that means that
dendritic cell is able to make a
connection between all these army
divisions and that is how they serve as
an important bridge between in debt and
the adaptive immune system I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
please leave your comment below because
it takes a lot of effort to make these
kind of videos do let me know how you
liked my video or you have any specific
situation your feedback and make the
contents even more better thank you